maintenant c'est l'interview boîte
vocale
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie des
monty python si vous nous avez piqué des
sketches veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore c'est à vous claque
moi j'ai raccroché ouais
on leur a rien volé à l'averse de
certains certains autres vers des monty
python qui ne nous ont volé des trucs
qu'on avait l'intention de faire a eu
longtemps après bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie d'ophélie winter si vous êtes
prêts à faire la une de voici veuillez
laisse un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous salue ici d'homme ça va
bonjour vous êtes sur un message de
michel drucker merci beaucoup de
m'appeler vraiment merci veuillez
laisser votre message après le bip
sonore quand va tâcher n
allait pas la famille bonjour vous êtes
sur la messagerie de bruno carette shops
sont pour le moment mais laissez votre
message après le bip sonore
pourquoi ouais le seul truc qu'on sait
c'est qu'à un moment ou à l'autre voire
ouais ça c'est un peu nouveau ouais
bonjour vous êtes sûrs et messagerie de
bertrand méheut si vous avez l'esprit
canal veuillez laisser un message après
le bip sonore c'est à vous
salut c'est d'homme ça va
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
steven spielberg je sais ça calme
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore ouais c'est gentil ça va on le
fera pas ce film donc ça va une façon
t'as pas les moyens donc laisse tomber
tu feras pas l'intégrer de 3,9 à eau
bonjour vous êtes sur les messageries de
jean marie messier si c'est pas pour de
l'argent veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore 9 jean-marie
toujours à moitié 18
qu'est ce que tu veux
bonjour bien sur la messagerie de nicole
kidman si vous êtes dominique farrugia
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore ni chorale je suis pris les
semoirs 6 hume ça suffit je rappellerai
quand même
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
ppda je suis chez mon coiffeur ou alors
on va y aller c'est votre message ça
devrait être rapide tu peux me rappeler
que
je joue de stéphane bern gardien de
l'esprit canal
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore garde le bien
[Rires]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie des
nuls nous sommes en tournée le vin chez
ardisson le 25 chez denisot le 26 chez
cauet le 27 chéchin le 28 chez pascal
klein le 22 à asnières complémentaires
34 veuillez laisser votre message après
le bip sonore s'il vous plaît nous
serons aussi en signature à la fnac le
tremplin p1 et le pont de et quelqu'un
une vanne win32 c'est pas possible à
baba
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux